my name is Nick Jonas and I'm going
undercover on the Internet
it's actually me first up Twitter was
told I look like Nick Jonas today what
do you think
I think the eyebrows are strong however
if we really did look alike I'd have to
throw that beard a bit longer sans
mustache question mark tapping the
submit button okay but when did Nick
Jonas get so hot
like most people I aged once a year and
with that came puberty and eventually I
turned into the person I am today is it
fine if your teenage crush on Nick Jonas
never goes away definitely asking for a
friend
well it would appear to me you're not
asking for a friend and I think it's
totally fine for it to stay responded to
let it for real it's actually me not
sure what the rest of the brothers are
up to but Nick Jonas just keeps getting
better or do his pants keep getting
tighter it's really a pants getting
tighter thing and a shirts getting
tighter thing it's it's trust me it's
nothing else I can assure you of that
is Nick Jonas two certified singles
artist now I never see any mention about
cutting albums no there's there's been a
couple albums you just maybe you missed
those along the way I can give you the
titles if you like and some links to go
and download the album's like a good
citizen nuff said
about some Cora his Nick Jonas a better
singer or actor an equal level singer
and actor he puts a lot of effort into
both and he cares about his craft so
making him choose is really offensive if
my girlfriend has sex with another guy
Nick Jonas in her dream is that
considered cheating hmm it seems I've
Freddy Krueger's your girlfriend
sexually in her dream but I will say
this it's not cheating if it's not the
real thing
don't let these fluid dreams
relationship let's go to you two it's
not why am i replaying the song over and
over and I'm almost 19 years old
partnering with Sesame Street was the
highlight of my career and clearly my
best musical performance ever so I'm
glad you think so too
hey buddy you in London this goes back
to a comment I left for somebody one
time people started sending this to me a
lot as well I don't know if it was
suggestive or if London was like a code
word for something I wasn't aware of but
it was simply just to ask a friend are
you actually in London and I'm not no
this photo was taken in New York City
and I'm fairly new york city sent who
wouldn't have sex with Nick Jonas PS I'm
using my dad's account to comment this
is cruel and hilarious and I respect you
for it well done y'all remember when he
wasn't even the hot one like every girl
had a crush on that other one I don't
remember his name but it was a cool name
like Joe or something well you clearly
know what his name was
I'm a little offended but also I think
it's very sweet that you now think I'm
the quote hot one so thanks for your
comment I'm not going to mention to Joe
either Yahoo Answers does Nick Jones
have a pet mouse I don't have a pet
mouse I have a pet dog named Elvis Lee
is very handsome
what does Nick Jonas look for in a girl
truth care the ability to mesh well with
friends and I think someone that
probably doesn't ask questions like what
does Nick Jonas a Florida girl on Yahoo
Answers but who knows maybe we could
work something out I'm dB
I know it's hard to believe but it's
actually made trademarks dark curly hair
dark brown eyes diabetic dog tech it's
odd to me that the dog tag is a
trademark and not the diabetes but it's
it's fine any additional trademarks I've
got a bunch of moles that kind of look
like a little dipper on
what else I'd like to believe that I
take very good care of my toenails which
most people don't get the chance to see
it's a shame because they're really well
taken care of so good toenails and enter
now let's go to Wikipedia no like it's
actually me he began performing on
Broadway at the age of seven portraying
characters such as Tiny Tim and Gavroche
among other roles yes that's true I also
played chip two teacup and beating the
Beast and little Jake and Annie Get Your
Gun with Reba McEntire hosted answers
calm which Jonas brother is the most
ticklish well I can honestly tell you
I've never tickled my brother so I
wouldn't know although that sounds like
just start to a really interesting adult
film
why does Nick Jonas cry emotional movies
Lion King for instance that makes me cry
lately on airplane specifically any
movie makes me cry under which the
pressure but it's happening a lot more
and more and I have to hide my face and
cry into a blanket because it's so
embarrassing back to Twitter wait Nick
Jonas has more than one sibling three in
fact they're all great people they're
just really fabulous and happy to have
them officially answered it reads 914
2016 and that is the day that I met
Nicholas himself during the future an
outdoor Wow that is a fantastic tattoo I
would be so nervous though that the
numbers would be incorrect and I would
think it was the right numbers and then
someone would later tell me that it was
wrong so I'm hoping that's not the case
with you Instagram fun fact I've walked
this hallway does that make me famous
you can superimpose yourself in this
photograph and perhaps you might be
famous then not because I'm in it just
because the Red Solo cups there and
let's all go cups are very popular among
the kids these days I usually don't draw
male portraits because I found myself it
have some difficulty of man faces
especially the jaws and chin
but I kind of like it with what I have
done well
Nick Jonas portrait finally yay nerd
glasses sparkles unicorn
I think the lips are maybe just a touch
more pink than mine a little bit more
red and it looks like my hair is gray
but other than that I think it's pretty
spot-on
maybe just take away the gray hairs
please thank you well that was a good
time and then that's a weird place see
you next time
why do I cry I don't cry what makes you
think I cry